même si beaucoup de cuisiniers fustige
son intransigeance tous attendent avec
impatience voix ans et brigitte et son
verdict chaque année le guide michelin
2008 ne sera en librairie que je dis
mais le voile a été levé tôt ce matin
sur les disgrâces et les promotions
décidées cette année triste nouvelle
pour le grand véfour ce restaurant
parisien perd sa troisième étoile à
marseille gérald passédat atteint le
firmament jean jacques peyraud marc
felix le plus beau panorama dont on
puisse rêver pour un restaurant c'est ce
qui avait séduit le grand père quand il
avait acheté la maison en 1917
jean paul lepers lui succède en 47 c'est
lui qui gagne les deux premières étoiles
et puis gerald prend la relève à son
tour il y a dix huit ans il fallait
absolument que je pose ma voix culinaire
sinon je n'aurais fait que petit fils de
ou ses pairs etc
mais ce n'était pas du tout le but
recherché j'avais tellement de choses à
exprimer que je me suis retranchée dans
ma cuisine et c'est à partir son aura
comme j'ai pu exploser là dedans inspiré
à la fois par la cuisine expérimentale
du catalan ferran adria et par la
tradition de ses maîtres
guérard et troisgros il invente alors de
nouvelles cuisson pour les poissons et
les crustacés la mer l'inspirent
il l'appelle son potager du poisson cru
il est vraiment dans la cuisine moderne
d'aujourd'hui les clients adorent sa
bouillabaisse elles marient à merveille
l'ancien et le renouveau les critiques
gastronomiques ont déjà repéré un très
grand nous l'avons suivi au cours des
deux dernières années
l'an dernier nous l'avions mis espoirs
trois étoiles ce qui voulait dire qu'il
était proche et de juste une question de
régularité cette année nous l'avons
suivi encore plus de fois et donc cette
année il est véritablement consacré
trois étoiles consacré comme une des 26
meilleures tables de france est une des
68 meilleure table du monde on ne faut
pas s'endormir là dessus il faut
absolument rebondir pour faire d'autres
choses encore plus intéressantes
je parle pour point de vue culinaire
d'aller plus loin de creuser
cette voie à 48 ans gérald passédat est
au sommet de son art pour son équipe et
lui le défi maintenant sera d'y rester